hello welcome we were just talking about
Jim he was at the UFC fight and he got a
picture with Paul Giamatti but Paul
Giamatti hated him oh just hated him
watch act nothing to do with me
humiliating right yeah that's not a guy
who's willing he's like okay I'll take
the photo and I was like I'll smile for
the photo but I don't want to do this
well we're just at a sporting event and
I it's a blurry picture for UFC right so
why why just to watch it I just enjoy it
what do i I just mean like it is sort of
like negative you know sort of [ __ ]
way like you kill him with kindness what
does that involve legs sure
okay so I'll tell you what it comes from
see my father was a boxing promoter and
so I was raised that anything involving
legs is like for losers and you're only
supposed to be like way stands yes oh
wow that's the boxing mentality right
that's what I'm saying
they need their legs they have to move
around and shuffle to the left like UFC
it's a lot of kicking in a cage yes it's
harder than boxing yeah I mean your dad
probably had a bias because he's a
promoter I think so right so he didn't
want people you wanted pp wanted the
other thing to be not cool but I think
what it is is that I know so little
about any of it frankly that I'm just
wrong with what I know from childhood
which is like only boxing is good
wrestling is bad anything if it's not
boxing it sucks it was not back saying
it's like yeah it's it's full of [ __ ]
basic so your dad makes it makes fake
right and it makes it so that you like
you don't have to be like oh I don't
know about that you could just be like a
blanket statement oh that's stupid which
I like doing and it was a good blanket
philosophy right we're mostly in Israel
his goal is to be the Don King of Israel
it was the 80s okay I was like a dream
sure people had their spot huh to be the
Don King of their spot that was just
kind of right which was we were from New
York but like he moved out to his
for tax evasion reasons and the the plan
was to become the Don King of Israel
what was he being falsely accused of tax
evasion is that what happened to Don oh
no Don would say that I'm sure yeah most
people say that they're falsely accuse
rataxes was your dad did he really evade
taxes yes I RS comes after me for my
dead daddy's Texas that's where I draw
the line
did you go to Israel oh yeah you went
with him how long do you spend there
little of a belligerent interviewee it's
just like why you [ __ ] I lived it for
two years okay and then did you eating
come back though cuz he was still
evading taxes I left him there cuz then
I was on the run 1988 at that point
right and to get out of town I mean I
was carrying folk loads of cocaine back
from Haifa Zell relived uh no he was in
says areia idea
do you speak Irish or Hebrew I don't
speak it'sh uh and I speak like a little
bit of Hebrew but not much and obviously
you know it's a not a hot territory in
general out there right you know right
it's not the greatest place to be in the
world
no and why me in some ways sure but I'm
saying some you know what yours
complicated region
uh the Intifada 86 to 88 okay I think
that's the first one guys that the
uprising the Intifada yeah I think it's
between the Gaza Strip and there's it's
like the I think it's the original as
far as I understand it which is limited
because of my IQ and miscellaneous other
reasons sure as stupid as reading yeah
just like a baseline know what I would
say my own baseline stupidity yes yes
like you're like major UFC type so I'm
mostly on the UFC tired here I like
professional wrestling
oh so you're the smart one
yeah
so what do you leave you go like dead
like I understand you know you can't be
back in the States right now things
aren't good but I got it I gotta go like
daddy daddy daddy I get it man I can't
be here huh
yeah I was like baby you know what calls
dead was it scary like was running it
like wizard wait I'm 6 to 8 years old my
favorite movies Rocky um and so you know
what I mean yeah crazy times some that
when I see that movie American hustle
yeah I'm like this is [ __ ] mincemeat
you know what about what it felt like
back what did any of that have to do
with your favorite movie being Rocky
yeah it really was a non sequitur it
didn't I just think that was I think I
was like it was a very tough guy
mentality I see ice because it was like
boxing promoting whatever but the
general the feeling of well I would say
that actually you know what I remember
back then is I remember there would be
like Israeli army soldiers and you would
pick them up hitchhiking like it was
normal you know when they would have
like an m16 and but that may just be how
you gave back to the Troops I think was
just like it felt very different than I
remember after 9/11 in New York they
started incorporating that idea of like
if you see something say something right
which was always had been like I just
remember as like a concept from sort of
like the equivalent of a fire drill in
the year and a half I went to school
there Elementary School sort of in the
third and fourth grades they did there
and they would do instead of fire drills
they would have like bomb drills and so
I remember like after 9/11 really
feeling like suddenly that was all very
familiar yeah yeah and then I'd been
back there recently and for like a work
reason in other words not tax evasion
and and I noticed that like that type of
[ __ ] wasn't going on anymore like the
world I think has changed very much
right anyway like things were already so
[ __ ] up like that's what's so crazy
about life anyway things are always so
[ __ ] up you cannot imagine a time that
is going to be more [ __ ] up because
surely they'll fix it and they somehow
they find the way to Trump it right it's
more [ __ ]
yes right it happened so when did you
start acting that cuz you're acting as a
callback that I was already I was in
pictures in Israel even I was cuz I was
acting already here before I laughed
pee-wee's Playhouse right was like my
big first gig in the in the city of New
York so you going like we're really
moving in Israel I got pee-wee's
Playhouse I'm like daddy Betty what do
we got yeah you [ __ ] with my business
man right and how do you audition from
Israel for pee-wee's Playhouse in New
York before the I was already doing that
in New York and then so when I went
there I did a couple of pictures there
Israeli pictures a one yes one when is
in Hebrew if I remember oh use but you
don't speak Hebrew at the time I did a
little bit okay he forgot because you
know children a Boris right adults like
you know rocks right right like you know
dead rocks here we play in the in the
Israeli movie uh one time I did a few
things there one time them all here
today so one thing I just remember being
in a hot-air balloon okay
balloon kid and I'm assuming there's a
hot air balloon picture right yeah well
of course you were the star no I don't
think I was actually oh oh just the hot
air balloon scene then did you like
being in a hot air balloon oh if right
mom I [ __ ] hate them
no that's when you go into like talking
like an old Italian man go up in the sky
what's nice though pizza pepperoni
you're staring the sauce up in the
[ __ ] you're in your wheelchair now
I'm just giving Corrigan and Goodfellas
right it's good it's great so you get
back to the states and were you able to
start acting again quickly oh yeah you
look sweet that means very quickly right
yeah right exactly right French yeah
Dennis the Menace I was in I played
venice's babysitter was that 93
anymore you said we would have said yeah
78 yep exactly we don't know you guys
prepared for this well yeah and that
what a movie I'm Erica Menace Walter
Matthau
Lloyd Joan Plowright nobody ever [ __ ]
drops Joan Plowright anymore I don't
know she is that one's white I didn't
know that was concentrating on him I
thought that was gonna be pictures Joan
plower I never heard of I'm sure I know
who she was by seeing her with him I
never heard the name Joan Plowright wait
I think I'm wrong she's definitely not
does it make sense whose back to
somebody hotter than that word yes do it
yes Joanne Woodward oh my god I'm such a
bad I was looking at this power I'm gone
like I brought the Paul Newman would do
better the plots of three no more rating
system that was a little first thing to
go
you're right you're right I apologize
for that yeah yeah well it wasn't right
of me you know what I'm gonna need what
oh yes Christopher Lloyd yeah I remember
when Dennis the Menace came out I was I
was a young boy I was very excited for
the Dennis the Menace about him this
slingshot right you don't see a lot of
slingshots in the movies anymore I would
go it I went into my yard yeah it was
him in Bart Simpson and I was like I'm
gonna make a slingshot and I got some
elastic and I got it too as terrible at
it I couldn't do any of the tricks to
Dennis I do so high really difficult
really difficult and it was such a
terror
but this Dennis the Menace yeah he
didn't do anything with himself he
didn't end up becoming a big a big stars
I don't know maybe he's a major
businessman to something yeah he could
be not just showbiz
but you on the other hand now man you
become a big star fish I would say so
yeah you're promoted by the way year
ball master is nine thousand nine
Sundays in midnight on Adult Swim yeah
yeah you don't just get ball masters to
anybody you're a big yeah start what is
9009 what's it what's that mean do you
know what I didn't know that was a part
of the title until I started so I
thought it was his poem and my emails I
think it just said ball master
the year that it takes place ah so it's
in the future and I do like to show a
great deal um Sanna very crazy it's an
animated show very great the guy who did
Superjail right right that's a breed
right right
it's 15-minute show yeah it's an Adult
Swim yeah it's uh came out on Sunday
right so I guess it's on on Sundays
unless it was just the one Sunday I
think it's a show and you plague as
digsy mm-hmm you know who's a washed-up
superstar and notorious party girl who
after a spiral of destructive antics is
demoted to the worst team in the in the
game the leptons the game of course is
ball masters right so it's I think
because I think I sort of thought it was
like a rollerball thing but right I
think it's in the future it is in the
year nine thousand nine okay yeah yeah
what I mean whatever you say well that's
why I'm inclined to believe it is you're
really good the thing yeah now if you
want very very crazy traffic very I
really had a lot of fun doing it seven
thousand years you know what do you
thinks gonna happen in the next seven
thousand there's gonna be a ball Masters
yeah yeah what do you how do you see the
future I don't know but I think we'll be
a little bit different than things are
now but maybe not much I think it'd be
different the same I think ball masters
will be a big big sport Jesus is gonna
be just what like aliens and hot lava I
think there were probably not hot lava I
think there will be aliens but I think
by then we will have found a cure for
how long yeah I will be on other planets
[Laughter]
cancer a long time that's killing us
it's the [ __ ] hot lava getting when
you're kid what's more terrifying than
hot lava yeah we need to find a cure for
that volcanoes in Hawaii they're just a
filmer see the volcanoes crazy crazy did
they took the dinosaurs would you this
hot lava
after it cools off it becomes rocks so
whatever's under it it's daddy dunsky I
never get it back it's a rock now
whatever do you know that there was a
volcano in Japan that people were
committing suicide into
see and you know yeah that's a way to go
get that close
I guess you walk up to the river and
just jump that's what I've been doing
they built fences around now so you
can't do as a famous volcano in Japan
people jumping into so you would climb
up to a cliff just walk me through it
yeah hypothetically okay they made a
suicide bridge on top of the volcano
forever they did know why would kill
themselves listen I don't know what
people I'm not a city planner I don't
know I kid from Dennis the Menace
actually grow to be one of the city
planners no I heard that too I don't
know how long it takes yeah it died in
lava
it's like Mountain probably pretty quick
you're melting stuff yeah like do you
just melt right well you probably burn
to death but how long does it take I
don't know 20 25 minutes I was hoping
yes oh no no but the whole time that's
you were watch good television oh good
good like ball masters nine thousand
nine thank you there it is something
nice are you married don't swim not that
I'm aware of but you know I mean I do
any children I don't know think about
that time something baby I do have kids
out there yes I I don't know it's
different women say that sure I don't
know I don't know if it's if I was just
thinking the other day it would be
really crazy if women could have
children they don't know about like men
do do you know what I mean right
baby I didn't know it it would just be
crazy it's just it's a wild difference
that men and women get it started crying
no you probably haven't kids yeah but I
have a c-section scar you're like weird
the fact of that coming out oh oh oh no
no I yeah I just mean like if there was
some guy out there see you guys are
seeing it the other way right I think
though it was just like some poor sucker
out there and he was like you know what
I mean whatever 1999 max fish he's like
there's some skater out there raising my
baby that's how I picture it more right
oh my god thanks fish no I mean the bar
like Laurie saamana
website - that's why I'm asking ya
dominatrix domination domination website
what does that mean so your message
board for domination people domination /
subs Dom's yeah Oh like dominatrix fi
SCH yes I thought it was something about
like world domination and I was like
that is a [ __ ] up website to go on if
is CH was it name for Albert Fish don't
know F is CH maybe he never mean to max
fish guitar
I have not you know been there I haven't
you have Troy what kind of bar is it
Troy do you have my child be honest
Julie that's called a hipster kind of
rock and roll skater bar see yeah you
did say skater
could be could be I sometimes think that
that skaters are like the equivalent for
women of models but modelin yell
actually sir that attractive universally
I just think cuz they're like kind of
like lanky and kind of like their bodies
and they're sort of sleepy right and
like if you see them sprawled out in the
morning it's kind of relaxing right
because they kind of just lope around
and they don't you know that main
metaphysical existential right which is
how I imagine that men fantasize some
models maybe like I don't think men
think about models personalities you
know
yeah they don't think like Oh what would
she be like to hang out how do they how
do they see it like somebody to like
penetrate make love - yeah you guys yeah
you guys this is like a conversation in
the nine days right were you a model is
very healthy yet you just completely
brought us to that point they want you
to want to have sex well of course they
did that's that they're beautiful
that's the job come on to the right to
want you don't want them just their job
is to seduce you into whatever product
they're selling if they don't saw my
models aren't ugly that's why I don't do
it that's why you don't want model cuz
he's ugly
why wasn't saying that but I thought so
well maybe
but is that what you wanna models you
don't you never been you don't think
that they would ever be something like
do you think the way with the next wave
of the futures can be ugly modeling you
know at the present try if it helps you
sell something sure but I don't know why
they don't think it will help you sell
products probably because I bet it will
because people will be like oh my god
they're so brave they're getting just
regular people to go on and they'll get
a nice big PR way you guys are very
sitting right though thanks they don't
even show real nerds they show really
really good-looking people oh my god I
want a pair of glasses and oh boy I'm a
dork shut up show really unfuckable
nerds I think a lot of these tides are
turning I think you guys are talking
about like you know eighties models kind
of you know they're offered something I
feel like there's there's a bit of a
tractive robin thicke we're sure I think
titties out the whole time
no the robit remember that Robin Thicke
video channel all right to the truth a
bunch of she's a model from today okay
you go back to the dog go back to the
dog walking phone
I don't let me tell you something I
don't [ __ ] with these kind of
conversations I don't look at like you
know paparazzi photos of modern you know
what this conversation what I like
talking about dead people mostly you do
yeah person would you like to describe
that happy I just in general I think I'm
just more interested in dead people
right right and they can't come back
well no I just think that they're a
little bit they were historically
they're just a little bit more exciting
to me I think I like like a little bit
like dead musicians who's your favorite
dead musician Janis Joplin II tried to
be in her film about her right you know
I mean well I mean now I guess like Lou
Reed maybe a big Lou Reed fair guy once
alright that's what do you like you're
wearing a Guns and Roses t-shirt you
like Axl Rose more than Louie I did yes
I throw the devil horns up on the
elevator I'm real rock and roll yeah
rock and roll oh yeah let's say are you
disgusted by that that he likes axel
rose more than Lou Reed
I think it's you know I think it's like
a medium to me I mean I see I'm not like
blown away I don't think that each day
I'm just not a fan of Luther you've been
you've been judging Jim on his on his
choices of hobbies and interest because
I'm assuming you can handle I enjoy I
want glad look now we're looking Lou
read up on the screen right but you
always hit hit hit when you when you
were gonna play Janis Joplin did you get
close to getting that film and I think
he dropped out but were you close to it
or did you think you'd a really good
shot at which time it wasn't what didn't
you want additional a her you were going
to play her in a bogus a biography about
her biopic yeah yeah that's happened to
me multiple times in my life and each
time that it hasn't happened it's broken
my heart on a different and new level
can you sing like her or would have to
like will you did you look at val kilmer
or they have to have put in the singing
over you what did val kilmer do sang as
morrison and so did joaquin phoenix as
Johnny Cash and didn't Jamie Foxx do Ray
Charles that's right again yeah yeah I
would say I would assume that I can do
what val kilmer can do there it is I'm
gonna go ahead and yeah yeah did you
sing like her in the auditions yeah I
mean and probably realistically the
older I get and the more I smoked
probably the less I could sing like her
but I think the the very first time that
it was first up for discussion when I
was like maybe you know like 22 or
something I think back then I probably
have hit more of those but I don't have
some sort of a great Janis Joplin voice
or anything I think I would've had to
work sure today I think that I think I
could have pulled it off when you go
through it that many times yeah and it
breaks your heart every time yeah
do you now like if it came up again
would you be like okay let's just see
and buy or would you still get all
worked up about it and then have your
heart broken again
yeah the latter you would yeah you would
I think you have to I think yeah I think
that you know this is like the nature of
a life in the arts right is you have
citement yeah and highs and lows well it
sounds like you have to believe that
it's gonna happen right in order to yeah
it manifest it well it's not even I mean
like it's not like I'm
no I am here promoting my new book the
secret which I was gonna be on Adult
Swim by the way there's a movie they
want you to promote before we wrap up
yeah
Oh show dogs it's a it's a family film
and Will Arnett stars as an FBI agent
who has to solve a case at a show dog
pageant and his partner is ludicrous
terrific
who's a Rottweiler and I play a dog
groomer and Stanley Tucci's in it sons
of a coming it's that Beverly Hills
Chihuahua guy which was your favorite
movie
I liked it a lot I preferred the sequel
right there too there is actually a -
you can improv bailout